[Musique]
bonsoir
est-ce que vous me connaissez
oui non non
si je vous fais
Léo
tu es où oh c'est pas vrai s'il te plaît
réponds Philippe sont partis et j'ai un
démon dans la maison je fais quoi moi
pour aller consulter le livre des ombres
je vais essayer autre chose
monsieur Wilford et moi-même sommes très
heureux de vous accueillir à bord du
transpersonnel il est 10h du matin la
température extérieure est de -140
degrés Celsius je vous souhaite une
belle journée
voilà je m'appelle
Dominique vallée je suis comédienne
spécialisée dans le doublage
vous avez en haut piper la série child
holy Marie Combs et en haut à votre
droite
Mélanie dans la série snowpier le
transpersonnel Jennifer connu alors vous
pouvez employer si vous le voulez le
terme WW c'est bon la polémique a assez
duré donc ben chacun fait ce qu'il veut
mais c'est vrai qu'en général on préfère
être appelé comédien de parce qu'on est
comédien de théâtre comédien de cinéma
acteurs de cinéma on n'est pas théâtreur
téléviseur mais bon on arrête la
polémique doubleuse bah finalement ça me
va très bien après des études de danse
classique et contemporaine je me suis
retrouvée par hasard au Café de la Gare
le premier café théâtre de France le
tout premier dans l'équipe de Romain
Bouteille avec Coluche Patrick Dewaere
Henri Guybet Miou-Miou où je suis restée
7 ans ensuite je me suis allé au Théâtre
de la gaieté Montparnasse où là j'ai
tourné enfin j'ai joué la comédie encore
pendant trois ans je suis partie en
tournée et puis j'ai joué au cinéma à la
télé mais l'image ça n'a jamais été mon
truc vraiment pas alors par hasard a été
très important dans ma carrière je suis
entrée dans un studio de doublage où
j'ai enfin trouvé la voie X et la voix e
que j'étais venue chercher et ce depuis
presque 40 ans
qu'est-ce qui caractérise l'acteur de
doublage il est inconnu la preuve vous
ne me connaissez pas il est invisible
parce que derrière un micro et dans la
pénombre mais aussi invisible parce que
le doublage a toujours été
longtemps considéré comme un cimetière
d'acteurs raté le doublage a longtemps
eu cette image ringarde et pourtant
c'est dans les studios sombres que j'ai
pu exprimer toute ma créativité j'ai été
flic avocate j'ai été sorcière j'ai été
une petite fille un petit garçon j'ai
été une vieille femme j'ai été une
baleine j'ai été une souris et tellement
d'autres personnages que je n'aurais
jamais pu faire aux jouets au cinéma ou
sur scène d'un théâtre autre avantage la
voix vieillit beaucoup moins vite que le
corps je n'aime pas le même traitement
que ces actrices qui évoluent au cinéma
et qui trop souvent on recourt à la
chirurgie esthétique pour rester dans la
course
on sait maintenant que
une fois les 40 ans passés on arrive
dans un tunnel je vous parle des
actrices et des comédiennes et ce tunnel
s'appelle le tunnel des 50 on entre à
l'intérieur et là tout d'un coup bah
c'est noir c'est le désert on devient
invisible on n'existe plus grâce au
doublage moi je continue à exister alors
j'espère que on va trouver quelque chose
pour la voix un petit lifting parce que
je compte bien continuer encore dans 20
ans à faire du doublage
j'ai surtout à coeur de parler de
ce merveilleux métier qui sort enfin de
l'ombre grâce aux fans et grâce à la
magie d'internet car oui c'est le public
d'Internet qui a été le premier à nous
envoyer de la considération j'ai même
envie de dire de l'amour je suis donc
tombée dans le doublage par hasard
coopté par un copain comédien à l'époque
en 1983 on était
200 300 max n'importe qui pouvait
frapper à la porte entrée passer un
essai c'était un métier qui
n'intéressait personne depuis la
technique a beaucoup évolué mais reste
une technique qu'il faut savoir
maîtriser pour pouvoir jouer et c'est ça
le plus difficile c'est jouer la comédie
devant un micro immobile il faut savoir
faut pouvoir créer danser sauter pleurer
rire
tout ça sans bouger et il y a plein
d'infos à capter en très peu de temps
comme ça hop on doit pouvoir se mettre
dans la peau du personnage immédiatement
on ne voit jamais le film avant jamais
on ne connaît pas le texte à l'avance on
l'a pas d'ailleurs notre directeur
directrice artistique nous fait le pitch
du film vite fait nous explique notre
rôle vite fait les scènes sont
séquencées en plusieurs morceaux de
moins d'une minute on regarde la scène
une fois ou deux et c'est parti on se
lance
avant on avait le temps de revoir
plusieurs fois la scène la refaire
encore et encore et écouter ce qu'on
avait fait mais maintenant on a plus le
temps voilà pourquoi il faut être
comédien pour faire du doublage et nous
ne sommes pas une seule voix le travail
de la voix est particulièrement
intéressant il faut apprendre à moduler
sa voix pour un film ou une série à
force de pratiquer votre voix va
naturellement se rapprocher de la voie
originale pour les dessins animés les
animés japonais les jeux vidéos on a
plusieurs personnages de trois quatre
cinq même six
alors on transforme notre voix notre
tessiture on passe d'une tonalité à une
autre et là c'est de la création de voix
on peut on va en fait on a trois voix
vous tout le monde moi trois voix grave
médium aigu
et avec du travail on peut s'amuser à
aggraver sa voix la descendre on la
descendre de plus en plus bas on appuie
sur le sternum et là on va se mettre à
parler plus doucement pour avoir le
droit un peu plus sensuel comme Mélanie
dans snowpierceur ou moi je me suis
amusée à la prendre comme ça mais cette
voix qui est qui est grave qui est
sensuelle peut devenir très dur aussi
peut être une voie militaire comme dans
les jeux vidéo attention derrière toi
par exemple puis on va remonter tout
doucement pour se retrouver à notre voie
naturelle notre médium
qui notre voie parler pour beaucoup de
films où on n'a pas besoin de la changer
la Transformer on est comme ça puis on
va la remonter et on va essayer de se
souvenir de notre adolescence qui était
très chouette quand on allait se balader
avec les copines et puis au fur et à
mesure on va la remonter parce que tout
d'un coup on se souvient on a été une
toute petite fille elle était vraiment
toute petite cette petite fille elle
avait deux couettes de chaque côté et la
vie son copain Jean Jean c'était son
pote genre il aime bien faire du vélo
alors ils allaient faire du vélo tous
les deux et c'était vraiment chouette
voilà on peut s'amuser comme ça
indéfiniment et je peux vous garantir
qu'on se souvient de toute cette vous
ces voix ah il y en a une que je ne vous
ai pas faite très important la voix de
vieille
alors une fois qu'on est monté tout
là-haut on redescend on redescend un
petit peu voie normale et puis on va
commencer à
parler beaucoup plus doucement à
redescendre encore un peu à y mettre un
petit peu de tremblement comme ça et
vous dire bonjour je me présente je suis
mamie Caroline
et je suis très heureuse de vous
rencontrer et puis dans un dessin animé
on va vous demander d'exagérer et là
tout d'un coup ça va être une
très et qui est en plus très méchant
voilà je l'avais oublié celle-là ça
serait dommage
et donc voilà moi je me souviens de
toutes mes voies et il nous arrive même
parfois de sauver un film grâce à la
version française si si bon je parlerai
pas de la polémique un concernant VOVF
ceux qui sont pour ceux qui sont contre
chacun fait ce qu'il veut mais je suis
fière de pouvoir vous dire que le
doublage francophone français belge
québécois et le meilleur au monde
vous l'avez compris c'est un métier à
part entière moi je suis incapable de
jouer un match au PSG on est d'accord
et ben de même qu'un footballeur est
loin d'être au top pour doubler un film
ou alors en trichant énormément grâce à
la technique grâce à l'ingénieur du son
grâce au montage grâce au mixage tout ça
pour avoir une tête d'affiche ça
m'énerve carton rouge chacun son métier
on est d'accord
le son très important le son
l'ingénieur ingénieuse du son est ton
allié ton ami très cher c'est lui elle
qui va mettre en valeur ta voix venir la
chercher dans les moments d'émotion les
moments susurés ou au contraire
l'éloigner lors de
foule de cris de bagarre de guerre parce
que ça on peut pas s'amuser nous
approcher à nous reculer du micro ça
fait du bruit bref c'est lui qui gère ça
et c'est très confortable et quand tu as
une très longue phrase une phrase qui
n'en finit plus avec des mots compliqués
des noms propres improbables tu te
plantes systématiquement au milieu de la
phrase évidemment et bien et puis t'as
pas le temps de la refaire la phrase et
puis tu l'as déjà fait trois quatre fois
et puis on a pas le temps c'est l'époque
maintenant on a plus le temps de rien
donc il va falloir que ton injection il
te drop pile au milieu pour reprendre en
plein milieu d'une phrase
il y arrive il y arrive et toi ma tu es
soulagé quoi tu es contente tu es
contente parce que tu vas pas la refaire
et finalement ça ne s'entend pas du tout
ce sont des virtuoses tu viens de jouer
une scène d'émotion tout en
tout en rupture en subtilité avec des
pleurs mélangées à des rires bref la
scène du film et tout un coup
on se rend compte que il y a une phrase
au milieu des rires et des pleurs donc
tout est collé qui est trop courte ou
trop longue c'est-à-dire que ça ne va
pas sur la bouche de ton personnage et
ben là j'ai son il va recaler ça il et
toi tu as pas besoin de la refaire bon
ce sont des magiciens en fait on est une
équipe un triangle
comédienne directrice artistique
ingénieuse du son la même chose en
masculin et la même chose en mix voilà
quand on fait du doublage on est anonyme
dans l'obscurité mais heureusement
internet est une révolutionner tout ça
l'arrivée du jeu vidéo qui est encore
une technique différente qui est pour
beaucoup on travaille sans image
uniquement des phrases qui défilent sur
un écran on a une onde
qui est longue de la VO qu'on a dans le
casque et on doit être pile départ et
fin c'est tout
moi je dois vous avouer que c'est c'est
une expérience intéressante j'en fais
énormément mais je ne comprends jamais
rien donc je ne sais pas ce que je fais
mais je suis contente de le faire et
d'ailleurs vous pouvez me retrouver dans
dans Star Wars The Old Republic que je
fais depuis 18 ans je suis la personne
et qui je vous jouez si vous me
choisissez sur World of Warcraft sur
Call of Duty et dernièrement sur Diablo
4 voilà c'était la séquence auto promo
ce sont des plateformes numériques donc
qui ont fait exploser le doublage de 200
comédiens nous sommes passés à plus de
3000 et grâce à une femme base et au
voxophile tout a changé sur la manière
de voir le métier aujourd'hui je reçois
énormément de messages me demandant
comment entrer dans le monde du doublage
et franchement je réponds que maintenant
c'est très compliqué avant on pouvait
venir assister à une séance facilement
comme moi je l'ai fait par la suite
moi-même j'ai emmené des potes comédiens
comédiennes pour pour qu'ils assistent
qu'ils passent des essais enfin c'était
facile vraiment rien les portes
n'étaient pas fermées maintenant c'est
verrouillé il faut des codes des pas si
il faut mettre son oeil dans des trucs
enfin bref avec toutes ces épices
surtout les jeux vidéo qui vont
compliquer tout ça on doit
systématiquement signer des accords de
confidentialité interdiction de parler
ou de partager le produit sur les
réseaux sociaux tant qu'il n'est pas
sorti au cinéma à la télé ou sur
Internet
maintenant si tu es comédien que tu en
as très très envie vas-y fonce ça peut
ça peut marcher
je comprends c'est engouement ce métier
magique en plus il y a pas que vous
blague il y a les jeux vidéos dont je
vous ai parlé mais il y a aussi
le documentaire La Voice Sauveur le
docu-fiction l'audio description le
livre audio les podcasts la pub
je crois que je vous ai tout dit et puis
j'ai aussi accepté d'être coach lors de
stage pour comédien des stages de voix
je participe à des conventions en France
et en Belgique
pour rencontrer les fans et faire des
dédicaces des conférences j'aime voir à
quel point ça interpelle le public je
suis tellement heureuse de transmettre
mon métier
aujourd'hui je suis sortie de l'ombre
je suis ici devant vous sur cette scène
pour vous compter la voix X et la voix e
que j'ai choisi une emprunter
je vous remercie du fond du coeur de
m'avoir écoutée et dorénavant tendez
bien l'oreille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]